A new print ad for Kraft salad dressing is drawing quite the controversy,...
...with some saying it's just a little too "zesty."
Kraft released a new series of TV commercials...
...and a print ad that featured this hunky guy cooking food with Zesty salad dressing.
You could say they're suggestive.
Despite its "zesty" approach, the commercials have garnered praise online...
...and attracted more than 1.5 million views on YouTube.
But on May 24, Kraft might have crossed the line...
...when it sent out this tweet of the print ad from the Zesty guy's account.
The Zesty guy is pretty much naked and writes,...
"Me, you and a picnic blanket inside this week's @peoplemag."
"I've been waiting for you. #getzesty"
Just in case you forgot, this is still an ad for salad dressing.
But a Christian advocacy group, One Million Moms, which is often known to speak out,...
...cried foul, saying the ad is way too provocative.
The group calls the print ad "disgusting"...
...and says, "It's easy to see what the ad is really selling."
It's demanding people to take action and contact Kraft,...
...urging the company to discontinue the "Let's Get Zesty" campaign.
No word from Kraft yet on the controversy.
But as the story hit the media circuit,...
...many anchors had their own thoughts on the TV commercial versus the print ad.